puis 15 heures cet après-midi montréal
est sens dessus dessous à cause d'orages
violents et des pluies torrentielles il
ya même eu de la grêle à certains
endroits
[Musique]
désormais au delà de 100 mm en un peu
plus d'une heure c'est extrêmement
inquiétant cela
la ville
jean près par les grossistes en prépare
la couverture qui s'en venait par des
toilettes dans le sous sol
ce jour-là un amalgame de 20 de grêle de
pluie s'abat dans le coeur de la
métropole
alors c'est une ligne d'orages qui est
très longue c'est un de montréal jusqu'à
par an
lorsque là pour que de la grèce ça veut
dire que l'orage et s'étendait
verticalement très très facilement à 10
km d'altitude alors imaginez quand un
orage se forment et s'étend jusqu'à 10
kg mais d'être soulagé la quantité d'eau
qui est dans cette colonne le qui peut
tomber en un peu plus d'une heure il
tombe par endroits jusqu'à 105 mm de
pluie croyable durant tout le mois de
juillet normalement ils tombent 90
millimètres de pluie cette journée là en
un peu plus d'une heure il est tombé 103
mm au centre-ville
donc c'était très intense beaucoup
beaucoup de pluie en peu de temps le
réseau d'égouts peut supporter 40 mm à
l'heure les rues se transforme en
rivière
ils ont fait deux trois quatre pieds
d'eau si sa roue cette marée noire est
un sens et une voiture a fait à peu près
200 pieds a tourné par entraîner pour
tous
sur l'autoroute décarie en pleine heure
de pointe le niveau de l'eau atteint 3
mètres et demi on utilise les échelles
des pompiers pour évacuer les
automobilistes et ses plus de 400
voitures qui seront abandonnés sur les
autoroutes de la métropole
l'eau s'infiltre partout dans les
tunnels et forcent la fermeture du métro
on peut pas descendre dans le sur la fin
qui angola au niveau inférieur
il n'y avait rien à faire c'est un flot
continuel de 2,2 pouces d'épais du
descendant les marches
la ville est paralysée en quelques
minutes 43 mail appels sont logés ou 9e
alors que la moyenne est d'environ 2500
par jour autorités sont complètement
débordés à cause de la situation qui
prévaut en circulation où tout est
bloqué même les véhicules d'urgence en
peine à se rendre sur les lieux fonds de
secours ce sont de simples citoyens et
inquiète par exemple à évacuer une
résidence pour personnes âgées à c'est
un rite
sur l'est de montréal près de 50000 sous
sol sont inondés travail 350 mille
résidences sont privés d'électricité
leur branchement est difficile la
tempête va jusqu'à endommagé le réseau
informatique
hydro québec tout le plancher
d'informatique à la place d'erding a été
inondé et nous avons perdu tous les
outils informatiques et la tempête fait
deux morts en dollars d'aujourd'hui
les dommages s'élèvent à 1,1 milliard
très peu de gens seront indemnisés la
main et de la place à pas grand chose
non plus la belle île assurance non plus
ils veulent pas faire le plus mal et n'a
plus perdu doit revenir au complet
j'aimerais semaine de mai tiens cela dit
j'ai plus rien
québec avait bien promis quelque 40
millions $ en fonds d'urgence mais à
peine le quart de cette somme a été
distribué